OTHERS.
>> BILL BARR AND OBVIOUSLY A
VERY IMPORTANT STATEMENT TODAY.
YOU HEARD COMING INTO OUR
BROADCAST TONIGHT THE PRESIDENT
HAS MADE A VERY IMPORTANT
DECISION.
HE HAS DECIDED TO AT LEAST
TEMPORARILY FREEZE ANY
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION.
HE SAID THEY MUST IMPROVE OR
THEY WILL NOW FACE A PERMANENT
FREEZE.
IN A LETTER TO THE LEADER OF THE
W.H.O., THE PRESIDENT REMINDED
HIM BACK ON APRIL 14 HE
SUSPENDED U.S. CONTRIBUTIONS TO
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION,
PENDING AN INVESTIGATION BY THE
ADMINISTRATION OVER THE
ORGANIZATION’S FAILED RESPONSE
TO THE COVID-19 COVID-19 OUTBREA
THE REVIEWS SAYS, YES, THEY MADE
THE PROPER DECISION THAT LACKING
IN FURTHER IMPROVEMENTS AND MORE
TRANSPARENCY, THE FUNDS WILL
CONTINUE TO BE FROZEN,
RECAPPING, SHANNON, MONEY FOR
THE W.H.O., THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION, AND FROZEN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID THEY WILL
NOT GET ANOTHER CENT UNTIL THEY
MAKE SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES.
BACK TO YOU.